سؤال رائع يريد جميع المستثمرين
معرفة ما هو عرض المصعد الخاص بك في دقيقة واحدة ،
نعتقد أن الاتصال البشري
أمر بالغ الأهمية لرفاهية الإنتاجية
ورفاهية الناس ، هل يمكنني
مقاطعتك بسرعة ، نعم ما هي
المشكلة التي تحاول حلها لعدم وجود مشكلة
حقيقية؟  يعد الاتصال البشري في عالمنا
اليوم تحسين العلاقات مع
الزملاء أمرًا أساسيًا لتحسين المشاركة
عندما يتعين عليك تقديم ملخص في
غضون 60 ثانية حول ماهية
عملك ولجذب اهتمام الأشخاص ، هناك
طريقتان للقيام بذلك وأفضل طريقة
هي  قم بدمجها ، لذا ما هي المشكلة
التي تحاول حلها وكيف
يمكنك جعلها حقيقية حتى تتوصل
إلى المشكلة التي
تريد حلها بالفعل ، فأنت لا تعرف ما هي
ميزات المنتج الذي لا تعرف
ماذا  إنك تحاول أن تفعل
لماذا سيستخدم شخص ما منتجي
بدلاً من شخص آخر لديه
أعلى مستوى من النظافة للدفع وأي واحد
لديه أكبر
سوق  ستكون قادرًا على جعل
هذا مشروعًا ناجحًا ، من الأفضل كثيرًا
أن يكون لديك عدد قليل من الأشخاص
يحبون شيئًا ما بدلاً من أن يحب الكثير
من الناس شيئًا ما يحب عدد قليل من
الأشخاص شيئًا ما
بشغف ، يمكنك بعد ذلك نقل هذا
الشغف نحو شيء ما  عدا ذلك ، ما هي
السمة الرئيسية لرائد الأعمال التي
تحتاج إلى أن تتمتع بروح شخص ما هو الشخص الذي
لديه الاستعداد للتشمر عن سواعدك
ونوعًا من مجرد المضي قدمًا وإنجاز الأشياء ،
الأشخاص الذين يشرحون تجربتهم
أو الكتب مفيدة دائمًا ،
تحتاجها كثيرًا  عندما تفعل ذلك بنفسك
وأعتقد أن التوصية الكبيرة التي لدي
هنا في المنطقة لكثير من الناس هي
الانضمام إلى شركة ناشئة وقضاء بعض الوقت مع
أشخاص خاطروا للقيام بذلك
بأنفسهم ولكنهم تعلموا من
تجربتهم ثم انتقل بعد ذلك  وافعل
ذلك بنفسك
فلا حرج في الانضمام إلى شركة
ناشئة والتعلم من
تجربة التميز نعم